men should be the stable ones men don't
need to be crying in front of women and
ideally they're not splitting chores and
I don't mean that disrespectfully but I
don't I think that if a woman cannot
look up to you in some way then she
cannot respect you and if she cannot
respect you she cannot love you I
totally disagree totally I I totally
agree
[Music]
step forward if you agree with the
prompt men are designed to want to sleep
with multiple women
yeah let's say um I definitely agree
that uh men you know want to sleep with
multiple women I think it's natural
because uh one of the things are is
because we you know we have so much
sperm and that way you know we produce
so much sperm and that makes us want to
repopulate the Earth basically and so a
lot of times what happens is I think
that Society is telling men not to do
that for whatever reason you know what I
mean and some some guys fall into that
but I definitely believe that you know
men actually want to be with multiple
women because it's just a natural thing
in this this is why you hear all the
time you know men always cheating and
guys feel like they you know trying to
hide the cheating and everything like
that and if it was natural for them to
just want to be with that one woman then
cheating wouldn't even be an issue you
know what I'm saying so that's how I
look at it yeah I think uh for
The Way We Were cultured I agree with
that but also too just through human
history right for survival you I mean
maybe this is old school thinking but
it's just like for survival you need to
have lots of kids so someone's pregnant
how do you keep multiplying you just
more women right not saying is right or
wrong but it's just kind of the way I
think women even cheat too it's like 50
50. yeah I think women also some you
know want to do their thing you know I'm
saying in some situations you know what
I'm saying so I don't think it's just I
mean I think it's a natural like I feel
like because that desire is there it's
it's a natural thing for you know if
we're something specifically men that
desire to want to do it is natural in us
so then therefore you're going to want
to do it so I don't think it's a you
know a natural thing to just be with
this one woman but at the same time when
I'm with this one woman I only want to
stay with her it's almost like I'm lying
to myself if I just want to be with her
you know what I mean yeah I mean that
makes perfect sense but the question is
is that the end point is being with
multiple women the end point I'm of the
firm belief that is important to
position yourself as a man to have the
capacity to be with as many women as you
possibly can and position yourself in a
way where you understand female nature
and you maximize your potential as a man
and that's where I don't necessarily
agree that just because there's a deeper
desire to continue to do it means it's
going to be the most optimal thing for
you and your own ability to thrive at
the highest level and connect with God
here on Earth I was taught not to be
with multiple women right but it's like
especially I mean here's the thing
especially when you're in a relationship
right it's like it's better to grow
together with somebody than multiple
people which I totally agree but I think
in the dating terms it's like something
wrong with being multiple women uh
because I think that's just dating it's
experimenting it's finding other people
but are we naturally made to just always
be with one person it's like if that
were true then these first thoughts of
being with another woman even though I'm
in a committed relationship would never
occur but it comes up once in a while
but it doesn't mean them acting upon it
so in our life you're being generous
about saying once in a while probably
builds up quite a bit well it depends
what kind of relationship you're in I
guess or how how good of a day it is
right like but I would say for me if it
was totally natural even though I was
natured nurtured into only being with
one woman that these thoughts wouldn't
occur then right and the thing with me
I'm you know I'm not a monogamous so I
have I have a wife I have a girlfriend
and I still you know from time to time
hook up with other girls you know what I
mean and so and the thing is it's it it
feels regular to me it doesn't feel like
I'm trying to do it or or doing it
because I'm forcing myself it just feels
just natural like it's something I want
to do you know what I mean and so to not
do it feels unnatural you might just
want this one moment for a relationship
I can understand that but sexually
though I think it's all Bs yeah I agree
I think American absolutely be head over
heels in love with a woman and still
sleep with other women and then not mean
anything to him right and I think all
men have the proclivity to to want to
sleep with other women now whether
they're able to speak to that and
actually act on that or not or if
they've been able to buy like like you
said like religiously find a way to work
around it and I think religion has been
great for that because if it weren't for
religion we probably would not have
Society but I think what's most
important to identify is that a man
should create choice in his life and if
you have choice you should be able to do
as you wish particularly like in your
case like in my case if there's no
deceit exactly it's the lying that in my
opinion is actually the overall problem
when when guys you know tend to go
outside of a relationship they lie to
the woman right that's the problem so
when I was growing up I was under the
belief of just being with one woman
right like I was a virgin for a very
long time then one girl broke my heart
so that caused like a lot of insecurity
resentment towards the other side right
and then I just became like a man
for a little bit the problem is you have
guys who are monogamous but they're
monogamous because they're forced to be
monogamous in a way meaning that they
have no choice because they don't have
the skill to attract multiple women and
a lot of times they'll use that as
virtue signaling I would never do such a
thing well actually bro you can't all
right can the disagree step forward
I remember when I would like go on tour
and things like that
my friends would always try to encourage
me to like hook up with girls that were
on to me
but I wasn't really like into it and
it made me feel like weird like off like
there was something wrong with
and now I'm at a point in my life where
I feel like I'm only having sex with
multiple women so I'm not weird so I
quote unquote normal I feel like even
when I do have sex with these random
women it doesn't give me any
gratification and I know that comes with
like random sex in the end
but I know in the back of my mind that
like I just like simply don't enjoy this
like I've been with multiple women and
I've been with one woman and being with
one woman is just so peaceful as far as
like
telling young men that they're born this
way and that they should feel this way
it can really not do damage but just
sort of making you second-guess things
about yourself am I normal am I weird is
there something off about me everyone
else around me is saying that I have to
feel this way or I have to do these
things but yet I don't feel the courage
to do those things I would say that's
not true though I don't think that we
should promote men sleep with multiple
women I think that we should promote
choice and what feels right to you so in
your particular case I would never tell
you to sleep with multiple women I think
you might be doing the right thing to do
exactly what you're doing and not do it
or stop doing it it's not about pushing
it on a young man but I'll tell you
there's a lot of young men that have a
demon inside and maybe are really upset
and frustrated with themselves because
they feel a certain way and it's like oh
I'm coming out the closet I'm straight
you know or super straight or too
straight or whatever it is I think that
it's really going to be about Choice man
so if me to you I tell you if that you
don't feel good doing that man I
wouldn't do it at all yeah I agree in
your situation well what was happening
in this way I think a lot of times what
happens is you have guys who will have
sex with multiple women women because
they're trying to fill a void so it
shouldn't be about filling a void it
should be about you actually Desiring so
you don't desire to do it so which is
why you shouldn't do it but there are
guys who desire to do it but then
they're suppressing their desire and
then it's doing the same thing as you
not wanting to do it like they feel they
feel weird about not doing it but they
want to whereas you felt weird doing it
but you didn't want to I think it's a
society thing like what you just said
who's making people feel guilty about
not doing it other men the reason I
think women and men the question was do
you feel it meant to sleep with multiple
women or are they just
you know that's what they do and I don't
think that's true I think it's a part of
your character and which who you are I
do believe that if you say if you're
going to be honest with your partner
your partner is into it but do I believe
that we are biologically meant and it's
in our head because we have to procreate
and this and I don't believe that I
believe the reason we do it a lot is
because it's it's looked upon as a great
thing for men to have multiple women
women are saying for that same totally I
have one son and two daughters and I
know the difference of how I felt when
they were 15 they're in their 20s now
they were 15 versus him having multiple
partners or my daughter so if I could
struck a check for a million bucks and
never feel that feeling again I
absolutely would I really really would
it's something that I really hated
myself for and I felt very apart I grew
up in the south south Louisiana with a
Bible Belt and I felt very distant from
people around me because I had this urge
in me and could not understand why I was
so different like the biggest self-hate
I've ever felt in my life is over this
particular subject I thought I was
broken and I understand you and me again
I'm gonna come back with you know just
being around it and
me I'm bisexual I've always have been
but like you heard me say I've been
married to a woman for 30 years and I've
been committed for 30 years doesn't that
I don't have that desire it's my
character to say this is my person and
that's who I want to be with so that's
what you're making a character versus is
the drive I was gonna say I think that
goes back to oh we just built that way
because if we're just built that way as
men then there's multiple people that
I'm going to want to sleep with but I
think what I was under the impression
with that question was are we
biologically DNA created for that I say
yes but I loved and I agree with what
we're saying here it's like but as men
right in the culture and awareness and
being a human being having a
Consciousness Choice language we can
choose not to we can go against those
desires or urges and stuff if you feel
that desire and you're honest with your
partner I believe that it's true do I
believe that we are biologically meant
this we just biologically want to sleep
with more people because we have a penis
but clean our legs and not a vagina I
don't well let me ask you this though
because you said you're bisexual so does
that means you're attracting to men and
women right so if you're with a woman
boom aren't you also attracted to men so
wouldn't you want a man and a woman no
so you're just like I just want one in a
time I made a commitment and it's not
even like I'm like there's no urge to
what there's always words that's that's
what the Earth that's what we're talking
about us that doesn't mean that I'm
biologically I think men and women both
have urges where do you think the urge
is coming from though if it's not
biologically inside of you I think the
urge comes from I don't think it's a
biological thing creation not urge I
think with the urge creation Temptation
no but is Temptation bad like you say in
a way that's kind of like connotation I
don't think temptation's natural I don't
think it's a thing of
well then that goes back to all of us
then all of us are meant to sleep with
multiple people so then that's just a
whole different Society thing but it's
not just the question was is as men are
we and I don't think so but regardless I
think it's important to understand
because I I think we are and if we can
come to terms of that we can begin to
move past it if that's what we desire
but if we reject that idea that it's not
natural then we can't move past it if
that's something that someone wants to
do but do you agree it's just men do you
agree with that statement that is just
no I think it's women too okay that's
why I disagree oh no because we just
told the men right I agree that it's
meant and women what it sounded like was
and correct me if I'm wrong um
people started talking about like
infidelity and you know telling the
truth and
I think like the urges and things are
okay until you act upon it
um and that's when both adults just have
to have a conversation about you know
this isn't working out for me I still
want to you know sleep around or
whatever you want to call it it sounds
like some people want to have their cake
and eat it too which I don't necessarily
agree with but I think just as long as
all parties involved have an
understanding of what they're getting
into I I don't see the issue I mean
honestly I don't think I could say it
any better than he did um that which I
feel like most of us or all of us kind
of agree upon that in the end it is a
choice that like if you want to be in a
poly like a relationship that's fine as
long as I was in agreement obviously
don't you know be in a month I'm not
gonna monogamous relationship and then
you know
like single-handedly choose to you know
sleep without a woman without telling a
partner like that's when like issues
arise
hi this is ragni the director of this
episode you can now stream your favorite
episodes of Middle Ground on Spotify
whenever you like please like this video
if you enjoy watching it and subscribe
to our Channel now let's get back to the
video stop missing women are more
attractive than dominating women oh hell
yeah
hahaha
hell yeah listen my shirt says
submissive women are sexy okay so yeah
it's true man it's true and look I I
think one of the most beautiful things
about love is being able to fully take
care of a woman in every way whether
that's emotionally protecting providing
everything about that like every fairy
tale that was ever written for all the
time was about a man saving a woman from
a castle in the dragon right or some
sort of scenario like that and I think
that's absolutely beautiful and I have
nothing against women being empowered
but I do feel like the happiest women in
the world are the ones that look up to a
man and that he can fight every day to
love her and love his kids and his
family and provide and be that source of
something to actually look up to like I
believe a woman can admire a man and
it's very very healthy am I saying that
somebody that doesn't do that is not a
man no I would never but ideally the
relationships that are going to work the
relationships in let's say the 30s 40s
50s or or whenever you know we're we're
having nuclear family stay together
before we went off the gold standard and
inflation pushed everybody to have two
people have to have a job yeah dude I do
I think those relationships were much
happier when the man could lead a house
and be proud of going out and going to
work every day and fighting for his
family yeah I do yeah I think what we
have to do is we have to look at General
female happiness because that's really
what I'm into like I don't really care
what guys think of what girls think I
think I have a unique perspective in
that I've worked with a lot of high
performing women that operate in this
dominant role and I work with them for
the purpose of helping them be able to
reintegrate with that more submissive
connected intuitive part of themselves
that really is connected to their bodies
that if they were connected to their
bodies wouldn't be as dominant at least
in the presence of men and with every
woman that I've worked with there is
this deep deep desire regardless of what
she says externally to submit to the
leadership of a man that she knows can
properly hold down the emotional space
and really put her interest at the
Forefront right because soon as when a
woman is dominant over that man she
can't respect him is this impossible
right exactly and and the thing is the
thing is with submission is it's like if
you even look at the word submission sub
under a mission if I have a mission and
this woman is under my mission meaning
she's I'm leading her right then that is
a actual good relationship that's going
to flourish truly deep down every woman
would love nothing more than to be more
feminine in a role in a family and take
on that either that motherly role or
that nurturing role or the role that
feels supportive to the overall mission
of a man it's just got to be a man worth
getting behind and weak men are the
reason why this is a problem case in
point look at the workplace and you
don't see women applying for jobs to be
power line guys or hang steel at steel
companies they're not picking outside of
the United States Army being like why
won't you draft me they don't want that
smoke bro like this and that's okay
right and I can't I can't say enough
it's like as a man like you get to take
pride in taking care of a woman
protecting women what about your
daughters man you want to protect and
provide care for them that's okay let
them be feminine a strong man doesn't
need you to be a man he say fine you you
can be a woman you're safe sweetheart
you come with me right that's it
um
there was just a few things that I
disagree on
um I think that in 2023 especially I
think women just want to be able to look
to the side and see their partner as an
equal and I think a lot of women now are
I don't think they're trying to be men I
think what they're realizing is that the
qualities that they were looking for
them in they've always had it within
themselves if women are submissive
it's mostly for I I want to say like the
validation for the men I think they know
in the back of their heads like they
know now that they can do things on
their own but I don't think they
necessarily need a man but I think what
they're looking for is that intimacy to
have a partner but I don't think that
they require one oh no they do because
you know a lot of these girls they
usually go home and cry at night from
being lonely from not having a men they
have all these things and then they
don't they're they're upset they don't
have a man you know what I mean and I
heard you say that you know women want
to be the men's equal but you don't see
and maybe this could just be a societal
thing that a societal pressure but you
don't see women doing things that could
make them equal to the men you know see
the women approaching the men you don't
see the woman paying for the dates you
don't see the woman uh being more
assertive to the man you see what I'm
saying so where's that at because they
got options they got so much more
options than me I'll tell you what you
do see you see a high level of women on
antidepressants more than ever right and
I think that's a bunch of women trying
to cope with trying to be like a man
when really let me ask you a question
are you more attracted to a woman that
has a hot pan job or to a woman's Beauty
that doesn't matter it does matter it
does matter to me absolutely you could
what I would like to say a mother figure
rather than a woman absolutely not but I
would like to say that you're saying
that women you know have a higher you
know of antidepressants but man um I'm a
social worker so men one out of ten are
more likely to experience depression but
more likely to go undiagnosed and not
seek therapy or help so I do think and
women also you have to consider the
fluctuation in hormones pregnancy
because that can alter you know their
mental health so I think that's kind of
a moot point but I feel like you know
I'm not looking for a mother figure I'm
looking for an equal so I feel like with
you know if we're saying that women you
know they're like going home crying
looking for men I think it's also that
societal pressure that tells you at the
same time you have to have multiple
women they're telling the women you have
to have that one man that Husband by a
certain age have kids by a certain age
there's more pressure on them than there
is men and for
you know lack of a better term I think
men have gotten off a lot easier because
women have so much pressure and they get
judged more harshly than men do for
talking about back then when men used to
go home bring home the bacon or whatever
you know the the domestic violence rate
was pretty high during that time and
I'll also say that for people of color
we never really had the luxury of
working one job so my parents you know
their parents before them everybody
always had to work men and women so
there was always that equal opportunity
for them to be able to see that they
could do it together as opposed to put
that one pressure and I also would like
to ask if you guys find submissive women
more attractive than dominant women is
that because it makes you feel more
validated as a man or is there something
there that you feel like feeds into your
purpose as a man yeah well it's a
balance if I if I'm a dominant person I
need a submissive if I meet a dominant
woman we're gonna butt heads what if
that changes like what if she grows
because I would I would love everybody
to be able to grow throughout life what
if she starts becoming more dominant
does that is that like uh are you saying
if she starts becoming more dominant in
our relationship more dominant or equal
to your Dome oh yeah she's gone she's
finished yes we're done that's my thing
like look I got children I don't need
somebody else to take care of and I love
your thing about you know the prince
charming and everything but you know
what I need I need a badass woman who
can match my badass energy I work with
my wife and I'm gonna tell you I take
care of her she takes care of me and
she's badass and that's what I'm
attracted to I don't need a submissive
that I have someone to take care of and
then it's fine you know if she goes
through that but then I'll be there and
I will take care of her but I'm not
looking for somebody another child to
take care of and have to dominate and
talk you go over there this is where
we're going to go to dinner this we're
going to do that now that's why what he
was saying I was going to bring that
fact up too allowed him in a depressed
because they put him on this Shield of I
have to be the leader I have to do this
and you know who goes to get help first
women okay that I that totally makes
sense I think if we're talking about men
not ever dealing with their emotions it
makes sense for this argument that you
guys are talking about but I'm the firm
believer I have gotten a lot of therapy
in my life I've done a lot of things for
myself personally to resolve my own
internal conflict okay so it's a job of
alpha men the real integrated Alpha man
has the capacity to understand what he's
feeling why he's feeling the way that he
is articulating in a way that is
productive to the dynamic so a real man
is someone that understands himself
deeper at an emotional level has taken
the time to do that so he can show up as
a rock not so he can show up more
emotionally problem is is that if you're
super emotional when we talk about the
whole thing of being submissive or
dominant your woman is going to dominate
you because you're so emotional
emotionally unstable let's say that it's
emote let's stop using emotion let's
start using emotionally unstable since
you're so emotions against it well she's
going to dominate you and then she's
going to lose respect for you and that's
going to Teeter the Waters of the
relationship
so I mean you guys know dominatrix exist
for a reason
um and by the way I used to personal
train at dominatrix you guys are they're
clients yeah uh not me Cowboy I'm being
serious like it's a very hidden thing I
used to I used to date um High positions
of power very Alpha but like here's the
thing I think you guys put a little bit
too much pressure on yourselves it might
be a societal thing I've dated
submissive women before I find them
highly annoying sometimes I just want
somebody to pick a choice I like her
places she's got better taste than I do
when it comes to that kind of stuff so
please go ahead we do butt heads once in
a while because she is dominant but does
that mean she lost respect or attraction
for me we have no not at all and trust
me on that one so I think it does depend
on your energy you have a very high one
right maybe it doesn't mix well with
somebody who also has a really high
dominant energy I'm not saying that's
wrong because they exist for a reason
submissive people right but I just think
for me when it's very submissive I don't
find that as sexy I find that annoying
let's see that and no and that makes
sense and the reason see what happens is
the more masculine you are the more you
want the one to be submissive the more
more dominant she is than the more I
don't know I think I think I'm pretty
masculine dude and I don't want
somebody that's amazing I'm saying that
in that moment you're in your feminine
but go ahead if you and your wife have
like a conversation about a disagreement
and then you got like a healthy
conversation and then she ends up being
right in the situation would you
consider her dominating me no I consider
her right so what's your definition of
like Domin like like you always have to
be right no it's not about right or
wrong it's about who's running the show
so by her being right is that not her no
that's just her being right in that
conversation yeah a good a good leader
would allow someone else to be right a
good leader doesn't have to be right he
wants the team to win in fact I'd call a
man insecure if he wouldn't allow a
woman to be right on the subject she was
clearly I like that I do like that and
you know it goes back to the question of
like what do you find more attractive
because that's what we're talking about
yeah what's the preference it's a
preference one of the things you said is
like when you and your partner or
girlfriend get into something and it's
like a little heated like I get off on
that me I totally don't get off on that
like I need I don't need any backtop I
don't need any limp I don't need any
attitude I need it's my way of the
highway like I don't want none of it I
didn't even have a conversation in the
first place
no back talk I'm right that's a
different thing if we're talking if
we're if we're talking about a topic and
she's right about the topic that's just
how no I was talking about the type of
opinion of yours or things like no I'm
talking about disagrees with that you're
like an opinion you're saying you won't
know back no no no I'm not talking about
opinions I'm talking about decisions so
so we can have a conversation about a
topic but when it comes to a decision
the final decision is mine let me change
my words
right she said so if we say hey we want
to do she wants to do a b and c and I
say no I want to do dnf right we're
doing d e and f at the end of the day
now I will listen to what she says and
if I think a b and c sounds better then
I say okay yeah let's do a b and c
because that's something I'm talking in
the first place no no no in the
conversation no that's that's what I'm
saying if we're having a conversation
that's cool I'm saying the final
decision though is mine so you can speak
your mind but at the end of the day I'm
making the final piece I was like I'm
gonna let you talk yeah let's talk yes
in the end I don't really care yeah I
don't look at what I want no but no I
said it no I said I care I do I don't
want to touch upon the more thing with
like like let's let's clarify submissive
let's not get that mistaken between
incompetent like submissive does not
mean incompetent and I think you might
have been talking about women that could
be incompetent where they don't have the
capacity to take care of themselves at
all or make any type of decision so I
think there's definitely a difference in
how she shows up in the relationship
compared to being able to make decisions
in her everyday life sure but he doesn't
want them to make decisions well no no I
didn't say I don't want them to make
decisions no your decision is the final
no matter what some some of the
strongest women in the world right now
are sitting in submissive roles because
they're strong enough to think for
themselves and do if they feel good in
their heart because they're all women
that do want to be submissive naturally
and some of those women are the
strongest women in the world right now
especially when the world's telling them
to go be something that they don't want
to be I do agree that honestly it is a
choice it's a preference you know we
shouldn't speak upon like everybody
obviously like it's always a gray area
it's a range it's not it's not one or
it's not one side or the other and if
you guys want to be in a relationship
where the woman is submissive and the
woman also wants to be in the
relationship where the male is dominant
that's completely fine but the thing I
want to talk about more is the fact that
like you guys keep saying that like this
is what women want or that like all
women want this who are we to decide
what women want because first of all
we're not woman and second just because
of our personal experiences and our
lifetime about the people we we've
interacted with I feel like that's
something we need to take a step back
from and clarify that like no this is
just my personal opinion in the end we
don't know what women want woman knows
what they want not men I I have yet to
see a relationship because I would say a
relation Dynamic that is optimal has
deep connection where you could say
there's a deep friendship there but also
their sexual polarity and I've seen
Dynamics where there is a great
friendship there and there is connection
and they do live very cohesively but
when the woman is more dominant the
majority of the time I've yet to see a
dynamic where consistently over time
there is strong sexual polarity on her
end in a dynamic and that's fine like if
that's if that's what you've seen in
your lifetime that's completely fine
like that guy but then biology says that
I don't think it's just my personal
opinion I don't think but probably you
just surround yourself with yeah that's
the thing it's like just because you've
grown up in a certain area of where like
people are like that because like I
could say the same thing but on the
other side where I've seen plenty of
people and plan of relationships where
like that wasn't the case but then
they're like sexually fine you know that
they're perfectly line their polarity is
completely fine and they're happy and I
could say the same thing I could keep
going at you saying that like oh because
of what I've seen or what I've I've
experienced
dominant men it won't work but then
that's dumb because there are cases
where dominant one do work but there's
also cases where it doesn't
they're probably not going out saying
I'm so happy I'm dominant and I'm a
woman he's not going around saying that
you know they're just happy they stick
to themselves most of the time that
happened
I am great at sex
oh come on man
I mean I have a lot to learn
how so we're gonna be disgusting
prove it
right now bro this was a chance to
redeem yourself no no I know but it's
just hard actually I'm gonna go back
really good with my partner my my wife
I'm able to not only connect physically
physically but also emotionally you know
and then I think that's the biggest
trick I've learned not trick but the
thing I've learned about my years of
being with my partner you have to sort
of like you know keep the spice going I
would say uh you know I think the the
fact that we have a woman who keeps
coming back or who keeps wanting it I
think that you know that's a sign that
she thinks a great attacks you know
because he because she actively wants to
keep it going and keep it keep it you
know keep it uh going into that in that
direction I would I will say though I'm
better at sex with women I care about
yeah you know so I think and me being a
player and a guy who goes out and talks
a lot of different women
um you know if if my girlfriend or like
my wife or whatever like that sex is sex
would be great with the other girls it
can still be good but I know that I
don't really put in that much effort
because it's almost like I'm
masturbating with someone and eventually
you know I know your partner is like
comfortability what they like what they
don't like and things and that's how you
make sex a lot better instead of like
sleeping with a thousand percent plus
you love them right like so you knew if
you were gonna die today and you could
have sex with one person before you die
it would be that person like no matter
what like you could have every
supermodel every movie star everything
like all that like I want that
person Focus so much on like what they
like as well you know like you're kind
of there to like pleasure them you know
because you care about them so much
right which is why like you would hyper
fix it on like what do they like what
they don't like and you can easily like
adjust yourself and put in effort for
that person and like for instance it's
so true that you said that because my
wife and I we have this thing we call
the love menu okay you know why did we
invent the love menu we invented the
love menu because we have three children
and they're only two years apart they're
in the mid 20s now but you know think
about it two four six at home and I'm
working and she's doing her thing so we
found that in our young relationship
sometimes the other person might be
tired and like Turned but that's her
feelings that makes you kind of do this
type of thing so what we did is we come
up with a love menu of like here's
appetizers I might not be ready for the
full course tonight but here's your
appetizer because I know you like this
or here is your dessert or here's your
main course meal and we broke it into
those things so when we do come to each
other and we need that connection it's
not just like I'm tired I don't feel
like it it's kind of like well
what's going to happen we got a full
course meal tonight or we're just gonna
have some appetizers and that kept it
that's kept it spicy for us and also
like when you say making sure we're
pleasuring each other it's not just wham
bam thank you ma'am I need to get my
rocks off but like you know how are you
feeling about that and how are you
feeling about that because when you're
at a long-term committed relationship
you have to do that or it dies right and
I love that I love you talk about the
amount of intention that you live with
in regard to making sure that you're
always evolving with it always making
sure that it's spicy you just care I
think if you have a genuine care for the
other person that you're involved with
then maybe you're not great right then
and there but it will eventually develop
into being something that way so I love
that care that you demonstrate with that
I'm interested with you've been very
quiet doing this one you're usually like
all he said was look at the receipts you
know
he knows he knows it and look and that's
a very important thing right so I think
that as a man I hate to say actually I
don't hate to say uh that you should
come in confidently and I do find by and
largely it's kind of like you could have
the alpha beta argument I do that
thinking coming in kind of in in a
dominant way there's a reason 50 Shades
of Gray is so popular there's a reason
it's the most read book of all time
there's reason there's detail in it and
I think you can say so much to a woman
in sex without saying a word you know
what I'm saying it's about how you touch
or how you have your hands on her the
way you take over her in that way and
that's okay just knowing and seeing that
expression and seeing things that happen
and as a result of that is enough for me
to know where I stand on the subject the
only thing I disagree with you
is I agree with that energy that take
control energy and I think when woman
does love that but sometimes my wife
likes to take control and I love it well
get up there girl get up there girl and
do what you got to do you know I'll put
my hands behind my hand too yeah count
one hey don't worry yeah yeah but I'm
buying largely yeah yes and then when
she wants to but even when you're all
bottom man you're still doing work bro
it's all about dancing bro I don't get
naked but I have sex tattooed on my
chest
it's right here on my rib
okay all right it is like a it's like an
old one too not even like a
[Music]
I think the biggest thing I've ever
heard from my sexual partners is like
wow you really caught me off guard and I
think that's like a big part of it
so is this like an argument with myself
[Laughter]
tell us why you're terrible at sucks you
missed it he stripped I did see that I
saw it I I disagree because I just feel
like it's such a typical conversation
and belief that every guy believes are
great at sex and to be real when I talk
to my girlfriends none of them have good
sex with guys unless it's like you guys
said your partner then you can get
better at it right and you know what
they like so that's what I mean like I
think I'm great with my girlfriend but
if I was to generate and say like I'm
great at sex I'm like oh I didn't you
know almost every girl I slept with
before probably never even got off
really but to say like I'm great at sex
you know I can bring a dildo in I don't
know like it's just like I mean I'm
nothing against that I like all kinds I
didn't mention it
[Laughter]
I didn't get it but it's like I I just
feel like you know there's a lot for me
to learn even now with my partner and I
just like to say I'm great I also I
don't say that to myself because I think
that blocks me from something that I
might not be good at actually no I agree
I don't I completely agree with the
aspect that like honestly there's always
room for growth you know like going
around saying thinking that you're like
the best is like some it's not something
that I agree with but more so that like
especially with someone that you know
like a partner like that and you
actually want to give like give the
effort into you learn you know like it
doesn't always have to go like perfect
the first time you know you pick up
things like everyone's different you
know man and woman so like honestly like
it's but that's what I when I think when
that question says I'm great at sex like
you it that that to me tells me you
could line up 10 girls and nine out of
ten you would know exactly what to do
but then there's just like a confidence
like I am confident that I can achieve
good sex exactly right because that's
that's say because because the thing is
I look at it like because you're saying
well being the best you know you can't
really see me the best but I just
grabbed it I look at I look at it as I
am the best but I'm choosing to be to be
great with this person and so what I'm
saying is I can be really great with
this one other girl but I choose not to
and I do that purposely and the reason
why I do it purposely is because like I
was saying earlier when we talk about
friends with girls and all that other
stuff is that women have to earn good
that's how I look at it you understand
what I'm saying so if I'm if I'm with a
woman where's I just met you at the bar
and we're just hooking up I'll give you
I'll give you something like I said I
should say women should earn great but
I'll give her some good but it ain't
gonna be great because you haven't
earned it you're not my girl you haven't
done anything the extra mile for her
right exactly I'm not gonna go into
extra mile for a new girl I agreed with
the
I agree with the mentality but they're
not the the stage
I'm just not gonna do all that for a new
girl I'm not gonna do that so I can't so
I what I'm saying is is that the
greatness comes from within you to know
that you can but you have to make the
decision to do that and I think once and
most guys if they care about a woman
they'll do that because that woman in
some form of fashion has earned that
type of energy from him and that's how I
look at it it's like I completely agree
but I just want to change the word into
something else something similar but
that means a little different because
like you don't want to give as much
effort to like other people that you
don't really you see like long term with
but then like obviously if it's like a
partner or someone that you can see a
future with you know that you can keep
you know improving you can be like the
best you know for that person who thinks
that great sex is is more mental or more
physical who which one would you raise
your hand well which one say okay who
thinks that great sex is more mental I
mean it's more I think it's more mental
okay
who thinks great sex is more physical
the reason why I sat down and then I
step back is because stepping down uh it
was I mean sitting down it was just kind
of like that societal pressure of
you know we all agree like men have to
be uh really great and I had to check
myself out of my ego and take a step
back because it can't be 9 out of ten it
has to be 10 out of 10. I know I've had
you know one night stands and I can't
account for every single partner that
I've had if they had a great experience
or not I could just be honest with
myself and say I did my best but you
know for whoever is going to be my
partner next you have to have that
like that sense of like open-mindedness
in a way because what they might think
they want from you to make you great you
might not agree with even trying you
know I get what you're saying about
women having to earn uh great but I feel
like at the same time so so funny coming
out of your mouth I feel like
um I told you I'm a comedian I feel like
at the same time you know women's needs
are a lot different than men's in bed so
what might be you know easy for you like
a quick one too they're expecting you
know maybe more foreplay or more
physical intimacy or you know and with
the whole like BDSM with like 50 Shades
of Gray I think that appeal to like a
certain subset of women and their
fantasies but I don't think that
accounts for all women I think it's a
great fantasy but I think if you put
most women like really say do you want
that maybe like nah they really wanted
women should not be in position of power
game over just like his hand says I'm
the only one I think a woman can be in a
position of power only by herself but
not in relation to being in a
relationship with a man because when
she's in a relationship with a man the
man has to be the leader the man has to
be the one that's guiding the situation
Direct in the situation if it's in any
other situation by herself with work you
know with her friends or whatever she
can do whatever she wants to do
game over
your game is over
I first want to ask because there was a
lot of like like has to have to's but
like not really a reason behind it like
can I ask like what's your reason behind
like why a man has to be in the power
like in power why can't a woman be about
power is such a weird word I'll say more
like the leadership role and I and the
thing is is that a man has to lead a
woman he has to guide a woman because
what happens is that when it's the
opposite when a woman is leading that
man she usually loses respect for him
when she's in a relationship with a man
who is you know under her who's
submissive to her in a lot of different
situations then she starts to lose
respect for him because she's looking
for a man to lead and guide her if you
notice they have sex with the bad boys
but then the nice guys get tossed to the
side you see like why is that well if
you look at them psychologically they
have past traumas and issues probably
but like
look there's there's women for you right
I mean like oh you're on a different
scale what I would say some women want a
guy like you because they don't want to
do anything right they don't want to
take that position
um I'm around a lot of women who don't
want that they're they're in positions
of power not just in work career at home
uh I know a lot of them I do business I
find women much more pleasant to do
business with but when you're talking
about maybe being at home I don't know
it's just like I think when you get into
your part your end of the pond
it can get a little bit Mucky you know
what I mean and I I don't really
subscribe to that as well I heard you
said you were from New York I lived in
Manhattan for 30 years as a fashion
designer in the heart of Manhattan she
was working as a fashion editor I held
it down for the three kids I was the one
bringing the money home I was the one
doing that after after my son my
youngest went back to school she went
back to work I always wanted to have my
own collection she was like you should
do that now so guess what she had the
job she paid the bills while I was
building my company so I could be strong
in our relationship and be a man in our
relationship but I also got to know what
it means to have a partner next to me
and that's someone that I have to lead
well I think it's really really
important to specify what leading means
and so right now we're talking about you
talked about okay we do the chores
sometimes she pays more sometimes I pay
more I think it's looking at a really
superficial level I think what you look
at in a relationship when you look at
leadership and the one that is following
per se is who's the one holding down the
emotional space like who has the
capacity to show up as The Rock the
majority of the time in a Dynamic and if
that is the woman I believe for the most
part the polarity gets thrown off and
there will be a deficiency in the sexual
attraction that she'll have for you if
you are more excessively emotional and
unstable than your wife I do believe
that's going to lead to issues in the
relationship a man's job is to be the
mountain that a woman's emotional wave
to crash into
like straight up so women are always
going to be more emotional than men men
should be the stable ones men don't need
to be crying in front of women and
ideally they're not splitting chores and
I don't mean that disrespectfully but I
don't I think that if a woman cannot
look up to you in some way then she
cannot respect you and if she cannot
respect you she cannot love you um
so and the only reason I didn't come sit
down is because I have some really
really good women and Leadership roles
in my in my businesses and they are
absolute leaders now they might lead
under me but I think they stand alone as
leaders and I respect them enough that I
would never come sit down over that
particular statement because it's too
vague but in the relationship yes sir I
do agree that a man should be the leader
he should be the breadwinner and he
should be the one solving all the
problems out in the world and
emotionally at home
I'm glad again that you that YouTube's
safe for work it's fine but when it
comes to our relationship I got to be
the one to wear the pants and I remember
okay let's not say pants we'll use a
person's words I gotta be the mountain
that her emotions crash into
I tell you guys we can be very emotional
too and I know it's a lot of guys in my
55 years that are way emotional to some
of these women out here now they're
taking charge so I think that's no I
agree that you don't
agreement
and if you notice isn't it weird that
nowadays they're talking about all these
single sexless men and all these guys
having issues why do you think that is
they're between more emotional than ever
exactly I think no I think women are
putting up with less bull crap no yeah
they're not putting up I am not a
sexless single guy no I'm not saying you
no no I'm just saying this but no one
said you were my girlfriend is an
emotional rock for me that's what I mean
I'm sorry brother I gotta strongly
disagree with everything you say I'm
also a breadwinner right now she it
wasn't always like that though uh she's
going through a time and she wants to
actually do something for herself and I
totally support that but when it comes
to an emotional
what I really just said that analogy
look I mean I think that's the problem
also with a lot of uh toxicity that goes
on because some men a lot of men have
emotions they don't want to express it
and then it turns into this opposite
toxicity how do I know this I used to be
one of them me too there's a lot of
these like Rich millionaires are the
ones that like have huge High divorce
rates and things of that sort and I
think it's because they're just
genuinely unhappy like is your woman
with you for your security or do they
actually like you as a person and we're
starting to see that like yeah like yeah
women want me at first but I don't think
it ends well because after a while like
they want you for your security they
don't want you for who you are as a
person and things of that sort that's
why we see these Millionaires and all
these like really alpha males getting
high divorce rates because I think at
first if I thought was like money
doesn't make you awful yeah no not at
all man
yeah you educate me that's why I came
here
a man can just be friends with an
attractive woman
no technicalities bro
it's so I think it's all about again as
we've been saying before it's all about
choices
um I think if you find a woman
attractive it depends on you know are
you gonna choose to pursue her or not
um but for some of us you know like if
we're speaking from personal experience
I've met many attractive women
um and that's not the only thing that
you know I'm looking for it's also about
personality so she can be a 10 but if
it's like the personality is just you
know someone who doesn't challenge me on
a spiritual level emotional level
um someone who also is like emotionally
unavailable like then it doesn't really
matter I have friends who like you know
I would considered very attractive but
at the same time I could and when I
think about it I wouldn't be able to
stand like being alone in a room with
them for like more than like 10 minutes
here I mean I could acknowledge if like
certain female friends of mine are
attractive but doesn't mean I'm like
sexually attracted to them and it comes
to a point where like I see them as like
sisters are just such close friends that
even like the thought of them naked like
grosses me out because like like I just
don't see them that way I see them as
like very close like I almost like
family in some cases and things of that
sort and you know sometimes like you
grow up with certain women and like you
see them as like a sister and you see
them as a close friend and you just grow
up you don't see her like that
fundamentally what's what's natural and
what is possible I think are two
different things is it natural to not be
attracted to a very attractive woman to
you I don't think so but with a lot of
intention with it and your priorities
are elsewhere and you're very
intentional with how you're showing up
in that space I think you can do it I
think that was a question if it can be
done not if it's natural or not
foreign
if I'm attracted to you honestly I'm
trying to I'm trying to smash you
understand we gotta have sex and we have
to have to be in some type of sexual
situation or I don't really want to you
know interact with you on top of that I
don't believe in giving women
non-sexual attention unless we're in a
relationship and the reason why is
because I feel like uh non-sexual
attention from a man towards a woman is
very valuable so I'm not just giving you
that just to be friends you know so I'm
saying like I'm not just going to do
that for you and so what it is is that
if I'm going to do that for you you have
to be under my program which means that
we're in some sort of sexual
relationship between me and you you see
what I'm saying so that's how I look at
that I think that men and women can be
friends it's just not because the man
wants to most often it's the man is
trying to sleep with a woman right and
he's trying to hang around long enough
for her to slip up and make that I mean
let's keep it 100 exactly right so KN
they yes and that would have been the
technicality like when I saw you moving
I'm like
but but overall most of the time you're
not going to see a man be friends with a
very overweight woman you're not going
to see a man be friends with with a very
unattractive woman unless there's some
kind of financial reward there so by and
largely I don't buy guy friends
particularly with any girl I'm seeing
it's like yeah right I think when I
think about it like in the head of
Technology on the other side because I
you know I'm like yeah part of me really
believes that can happen but then I go
back to my experience in life and my
friends and it's really hard I I was
running over there in my head like
should I sit down but I was running all
these scenarios from life experience of
my friends who have said that girls and
guys because it's not just guys and it's
never worked out that way it just never
is and I think because and it's if you
find the person can be yes a person can
be an attractive person and you not find
that person attractive and you be
friends you have friendship attraction
that's my thing relationship is is
friendship and getting along and then on
top of it you find that person attracted
no way I just think it's a very rare
very rare thing you know just a person
can be attracted to me and you not
finding them attract active and I can be
friends with that person but if I'm
finding that or if you're finding that
person attractive and you build a
friendship connection and you connect
and you want to you probably want to be
with them I don't think Adam and Michael
said doesn't exist but to me just again
in my experience in life and just
knowing my friends and people I don't
know one that has worked out though I
mean there's nothing wrong with like
your old experiences obviously if that's
what you've seen or that's what new
person experience that like you yourself
couldn't be in a friendship with a woman
like again that's your personal
experience though whereas the question
is like can a man any man be in a like a
regular friendship with a woman like a
real real friendship like they're
actually really friends yeah and he not
want to sleep with her and find her
attractive right no yeah I think it's I
think it's BS because like at that point
like you also we're always talking about
like now we're talking about like what
is an attractive woman right are we
talking about just looks because in this
case like there are people who like
honestly don't don't like have sexual
like desires for a woman who isn't like
emotionally late I think it's is she
attractive to you yeah I think that's
like the basis of it when you look at
specific situations so for some of these
females that work for you for example if
they're very attractive do you feel I
would imagine you have the capacity to
kind of analyze that gift from God yeah
I mean I just the second I saw on their
check it's gone it's gone right so it's
just I think it's the same thing with
friends as significant others as well
it's like I have the ability to
compartmentalize it where it's like all
right this attraction it just dissipates
so is that the barrier that can make a
man attract a man attract a man friends
with an attractive woman if there's that
barrier of him being in the relationship
or you're working for them well first of
all we're not friends you work for me
right you know I care about you fully
you're part of the family but you work
for me we're not personal friends and me
and you will not be in the atmosphere
We're alone right so when you go back to
it is it a thing where if you're both
single do we all think that you could be
a friends with an attractive when we're
both single no no no I don't know
a man should not cry in front of his
kids
very popular it's not gonna be popular
to say this
but ideally you're not gonna cry in
front of your kids they cry to you is it
fair no is life Fair no
is the dynamic between a man a woman a
child Fair no but personally for me I
want to take that responsibility of
being the one that's stronger than all
of them and I'm okay with that I'm okay
with that responsibility I want that
responsibility in my life I want to feel
like I was a hero to them in every way
and I don't think a man that cries in
front of his family is not the hero but
ideally
I'm not going to be doing this right I
you know it's weird I've never actually
seen my dad cry to his day not even once
the kids is looking to their father for
that strength and so if they're seeing
their dad cry right I feel like that
creates fear in the situation the kid
has with their father if you're crying
in front of your kids it's the same
thing as crying in front of your girl it
it it's it's a it's a bad representation
of what you're supposed to be in that
situation for them now I'll tell you
when I do cry
bro when you see like one of those kids
with Down Syndrome get put in a high
school basketball game he starts nailing
threes and Jim goes crazy bro I'll be
chronic so if I'm so happy for the kids
it's like happy I'm like laughing I'm
like you know but other than that man uh
no not at all
ah
can the person who like has kids
I have a father who I've never seen cry
so I get that I was that man again but
you have to understand my kids my middle
girl my middle daughter who I'm going to
talk about is 26 years old now for some
reason out of all three of my children
that little girl from the time she
turned 13
to 1718 we just
butted heads but it hits right and the
relationship wasn't going to where it
should be going and I want to be close
to my kids we sat down she was about 20
maybe 19 20 years old we had a heart to
heart about our feelings and how we
really felt about each other and I cried
and
six years later some years later better
relationship than we've ever had because
she saw a human part of me and not just
me trying to be what you guys are
talking about which is a good thing too
you can count my my wife can count on
one hand how many times you see me cry I
think my son had and my other daughter
have it but I'm going to tell you for
that enriching moment and that's against
this coming with years of having those
tears with her and talking about how
important it was that our relationship
worked and then hear her come back and
sing she felt the same way and breaking
through that I'm the father I'm going to
be the strong one made her break down
and both of us be closer than we ever
have been can I ask you a question about
that do you think that if you could have
set her down earlier than the age that
you did and just had a vulnerable
conversation that maybe it could have
happened like it wouldn't have to build
all the way up to tears no she wouldn't
have been able to hear it or no because
what was going on from my understanding
of my relationship is that you know
young people I'm very independent my
children are very independent they don't
want to be controlled in a certain way
and as a father you still have to keep
that control she was only seeing that
side so she was only seeing this
domineering person trying to squish what
she thought that she wanted to be or who
she wanted to be and that wasn't it I
was just trying to play the father role
I saw my dad do it never it's here he's
that man you know and I was raised by
that man and I took that on I remember
sitting my son down and telling him Boys
Don't Cry
and I still to this day regret that and
I still talk to him he's 24. I still
talk to him about I was wrong because I
do not think that's the way we're
supposed to live our lives and I think
that's why you go back to the statistic
I had a lot of men are depressed we're
supposed to have emotions we're human
now I don't believe every time you turn
around you should be in front of your
children and your wife's like you know I
think that's a drastic thing
but I know dropping a tear as a father
for me made a relationship and so much
closer and so much better than they
would I'm telling you I know what that
it would have ever been do you don't
think you could have shown that
vulnerability without the tear no my dad
was capable of expressing emotion not
from the standpoint of being a whiny
little baby he held out held it down on
my family my parents are the happiest
couple ever seen still to this day but
my dad was able to and still is able to
at funerals be able to show emotion
during movies when he feels the emotion
to be able to show up and do that
um he I'd never see him whining about
like what you guys are saying whining
about just issues happening in his life
like at work and what he's doing never
he deals with that on his own but he is
showing a vulnerably when he is
experiencing an emotion not from a whiny
baby place but from a freeness that he
has with it and I even think like when I
first went off to college you know he's
he's tearing up too so I would just like
to say
um this is a field I specialize in I'm a
program manager for a non-profit that
focuses on mental health and a lot of
the times what we what we get in our
clients are men that are coming in
dealing with childhood trauma of these
expectations and standards of trying to
live up to the quote-unquote masculine
um ideal so a lot of the times we we
have men coming in because they're still
trying to seek approval in their 30s or
they're still trying to get that male
validation you know in their 40s and it
goes back to making sure we understand
the difference between regulating your
emotions and suppressing them I think
it's that's why I said earlier like to
be an alpha you have to be balanced you
guys can be emotional as well you guys
can be vulnerable it doesn't make you
less sad just like a woman being more
assertive doesn't make her less than a
woman if you feel like you don't want to
promote being emotional in front of your
kids you know I've asked the question
does that kind of fall into toxic
masculinity for your son well first I
didn't say anything about not being
vulnerable vulnerable is the word that I
brought up so I think being vulnerable
is very important I think crying
physically crying in front of your kids
not ideal this is not about an ego
stroke or trying to be overly masculine
I think being vulnerable as a man is one
of the strongest things a man can
actually do it's just that I don't think
that crime particularly sobbing is going
to be very healthy as the leader in the
person that they're supposed to come to
for that safety and that care but isn't
real vulnerability then then you're just
not being honest but like yeah sorry I
had this thing I just I left and I cried
but now I'm here to be strong
I can't think of a scenario where I'd
leave to cry yeah see I guess but
kneading feels performative
I'm trying to show you how vulnerable I
am it's no it's not necessarily showing
it's it I think he's going to be very
vulnerable without crying yeah people
just Express their sadness in different
ways you can be but I heard what you
guys were saying earlier and I agree
with that it's like you know you don't
want to be a crybaby about things we
don't right but it's like to be at for
instance if I'm at a funeral and this
person meant something to tell me no
can't do that or I see something on
television or a movie that moves me like
you can't do that it's like kind of like
a very
weird thing and I I think you guys
touched upon that it's just like a weird
stigma behind like crying because it
seems like we keep associating crying
with weakness and the issue is that like
again there is a big difference between
crying and solving so hysterically
solving like I think definitely do if
you like say you lost a loved one like
really close to you like like say like
you're significant other say like
probably accident like stuff like that
you know like there are obviously
scenarios for that for like regular
crying again kind of like we all touched
upon that we're not saying that you have
to cry every other day but like there
are like cases where it's it's okay it
should be okay as kids we look for like
we look up to our dads to be able to how
do we react to certain scenarios do you
feel that like okay like for instance
like my dad didn't cry I don't think
I've ever seen my dad cry I've seen very
bad like sad scenarios straight face you
know and
I feel like I developed that as like a
kid like as I got older like I have to
keep this inside because that's how
exactly just how I saw my dad do it how
would you basically like explain to your
kids how they feel like they should let
out their sadness should they keep
especially if you feel like you're not
really expressing side of scenes I think
probably the best thing I can do is like
explain to you what my goal as a father
is is to explain them the truth of the
world truly hey this is the truth of the
world this is how the world is
here's some competencies and things you
can do to set yourself up because my
ultimate goal for my children is to have
choice so I can have a son he could be
gay he could cry he could be straight he
could cry like like I could have
daughters that were dominant masculine I
don't care as long as they have choice I
personally my preference and and what I
aspire to be and what I want to be and
what I get to be is that strong man for
my family we all kind of believe that
like we have to be a hero for our kids
right especially when they're super
young and honestly I agree I think I
think it's totally like you need to be a
role model for your kids you know and
you need to be a safe space which I
completely agree with but things happen
as they grow up you know I mean
especially when they go towards their
teen years when they start being more in
touch with their emotions when they're
actually like feeling a lot of different
things and feeling the pressure of
society and everything that's collapsing
around them sometimes they don't just
need like a hero they need
a father to like commune with to like
actually talk with
you that way
[Laughter]
[Music]